okay I need your help with this next
segment I I really don't know what to
make of it and I'm coming to you because
I want to hear what you think so let me
set it up it's not a secret that former
New York City Mayor and possible Trump
lawyer we don't know if he's still
Trump's lawyer Rudy Giuliani he has
concerned many people with his excessive
drinking of alcohol there were a bunch
of prior reports that at one point
people around Trump were trying to
prevent Rudy from doing nighttime
appearances on Fox News and on other
networks because he would frequently go
to dinner and then drink too much and
then he would show up to the interviews
disheveled and not making any sense
several people sent me the same video
which we're going to look at shortly of
a Rudy Giuliani appearance two days ago
on Fox News and what's very interesting
about this one is that most people wrote
to me saying Rudy seems drunk his
glasses are crooked
both eyes look weird especially his left
eye whoo which kept being half closed
throughout the interview his reflexes
seem slowed most people were talking
about alcohol about this interview but I
heard from two people one of whom as far
as I know is not a medical professional
but one who is a medical professional
who said David this is a daytime
interview Rudi seems to drink at night
this struck the doctor that emailed me
more like some kind of opiate use of
some kind merely speculation to be clear
but from a medical professional who has
not personally examined Rudy Giuliani
but leaned us to say let's take a look I
want to hear from you because it for in
my view it's inconclusive let's look at
some of the clips let's listen to these
and I want to hear from you do you think
anything is going on here if you're
listening you're mostly listening for
that sort of slowed delivery if you're
watching you will see Rudy look sort of
strange when he wears the glasses
they're crooked his eyes are closing in
a way that seemingly is beyond his
control
it's all very weird let's take a look at
clip number one who want visas to come
to America to testify about Purisima
what would they say about Purisima and
hunter bono well you know it's real
simple this case is a this case has been
real simple from the day that Joe Biden
can
to committing bribery back in January of
2018 and the Council on Foreign
Relations didn't know anything about it
although he said precisely what was
attributed to President Trump a year and
a half later that caused all sorts of
them basically they'll prove that he
committed bribery the crime of bribery
is offering something of value to a
public official for official action
okay here's what Joe Biden says he did
he offered him a 1 billion dollar loan
guarantee he threatened him with a 1
billion dollar loan guarantee so at this
point other than the eyes closing he's
sort of repeating himself he's licking
his lips a lot kind of the circuitous
storytelling and lots of pauses it's not
anything totally obvious to me cut to a
few minutes later in the interview and
it starts to get weirder I admit by now
you'll notice Rudy sort of swaying left
to right as he talks left right left
right as that left eye seems even more
closed up well claims he claims that we
had a meeting with the president at the
Chanukah party right in December of 2000
at 18 somebody should remind Lev that
there were five witnesses including his
his good friend
Igor Froman who all say categorically
untrue provable by records he's trying
to make himself very important we never
had that meeting with the president now
it continues and in this next section
the swaying back and forth continues the
eyes closing continue but now Rudy's
voice does seem to get a little strange
almost like a version of vocal fry' and
he takes on a stranger demeanor plus
some strange sniffing that you might
pick up on ok real quick he had every
right to talk to him he effect it would
have been his duty to do so I don't even
I have no idea why this lawyer is
creating these additional problems I
love they're not problems for me because
there's so many witnesses and documents
to prove he's lying that's why I hate to
see sure I do this for a living right
and I hate to see a lawyer do this is
somebody ok you said it's not gonna hurt
you are you afraid mr. mayor that you
could be indicted oh wow how awful all
you've you known me I've known you
several years you
think I'm afraid I don't know I get
afraid well I did the right thing I
represented my client in a very very
effective way I was so effective that I
discovered a pattern of corruption that
the washington press has been covering
up for three or four years I don't know
I think this is inconclusive and you
know if one person had sent this to me I
probably wouldn't even be bringing it to
you but because five people contacted me
about it
three saying he seems drunk to saying
they think it's opiates one of those two
who's a medical professional I want to
bring it to you I I think it is
interesting that people who as far as I
know have nothing to do with each other
wrote to me about the same thing saying
similar but not exactly the same thing
in terms of their analysis I'm curious
what you think about it the drinking at
night is well-known this was a daytime
interview let me know your take on it
you can find the entire interview online
leave a reply if you are watching on
youtube or send me a tweet at Deep
hackman if you otherwise want to let me
know your thoughts make sure you're
following the david pakman show on
instagram at david pakman show a lot of
behind the scenes pictures
memes upcoming previews and a lot of
different things david pakman show on
instagram follow us there one of today's
sponsors is a game called dump Trump
which you can play for free on desktop
as well as iOS and Android when you go
to david pakman.com slash trump game
that's where you'll also find the
hilarious merch that they offer which
you can get for 10% off when you use the
code Pakman at checkout dump Trump is a
game where a nefarious man named Ronald
dump is trying to kidnap your cat it's
wacky but it's hilarious and the point
of the game is to find creative ways of
keeping Ronald dump from grabbing your
cat you understand what I'm saying right
it's an action-packed collection of 45
different minigames nearly all of them
have some political theme related to the
current administration every minigame
the only way to win is to stop the
orange antagonist the game itself is a
ton of fun but maybe the best part about
it is that when you first open the game
you get to choose which 2020 Democratic
primary can
you want your proceeds to go to and
every time you play the game a portion
of the revenue that comes from in-game
ads and any in-app purchases will go to
the 2020 Democratic candidate of your
choice and as part of this promotion
they're doing with us they'll be giving
an additional 25% to your favorite
candidate maybe you support Bernie or
Warren or Andrew yang regardless of who
you're pulling for in the Democratic
primary you can send small donations to
your favorite candidate just by playing
this game and it is a game I think
you'll have a lot of fun with it's
called dump Trump you can play it for
free on desktop or on your phone when
you go to david pakman.com slash trump
game and when you go there you can also
save 10% on dump Trump merchandise when
you use the coupon code Pakman at
checkout